[Music]
welcome back to our next episode of
what's up prof
hello walter good day again yes
we must stop meeting like this i think
the people will let us
[Music]
let's open with a word of prayer our
email and father thank you very much for
bringing us together
once again we ask that you bless this
discussions
and that you enlighten our minds again
with the holy spirit
and also bless the viewers in jesus name
amen
amen so we've got
a lot of questions again and we're going
to use this
episode to answer some of the questions
we do that occasionally yes
when the questions start heaping up
so will you guide us again and take us
in
with the first question okay
the first question that we received here
that we thought needed some discussion
was the identity of the rider on the
white horse
some people think it's antichrist maybe
because of going forth conquering and to
conquer
the rider in chapter six only has one
crown
the rider in chapter 19 has many crowns
now when we talk about the
writers of the apocalypse it's always
good to go to the book of revelation
and just to recap the book of revelation
is written in a chiastic structure
and then there are chiasms within
chiasms and epinados within
chiasms it's a it's a fascinating book
just for clarity maybe some viewers
don't know what a chiasm is
a chiasm is a particular structure that
is
written in reverse
one way a reverse way so that you get
the climax in the middle
that's one of the ways in which chiasm
is written or you have an a
b b a repetition
so that the center is a is a double
portion
that's why you can't cut out anything
out of the bible
so if he says for example i am the alpha
and the omega the first and the last
when he repeats that it's because
there's a chiastic structure
if you take out the repetition you
destroy the chiasm
so modern translations believe
that they need brevity of words and
destroy chiasms in that way
but god's word is full of chiasms
now the book of revelation is written as
i said in a in a chiasm
and the first half of the book leading
to
the climax in the middle is the historic
arm
and the second one is the
eschatological arm in other words things
pertaining to the
end and that is why it often appears
that the second
portion of the book of revelation
appears to be in reverse order
if you go to the devil that surrounds
the city
the resurrection takes place after he
surrounded the city because it's in
reverse order because the chiasm
requires it
otherwise you get confused in this book
so it's firstly important to realize
that the writers of the apocalypse which
are in chapter 6
they are in the historic arm yeah
so they have a historic progression
through time and therefore
it cannot be the antichrist that sits on
this white horse
because that would destroy the historic
continuous
progress from the beginnings of the
gospel herald
to the end he comes according to modern
theology
at the end but according to biblical
theology it comes somewhere in the
middle
right yes and uh so we have to
we have to deal with that now it says
in chapter 6 in verse 2
and i saw him behold a white horse and
he that sat on it
had a bow and a crown was given him
and he went forth conquering and to
conquer now
horse in the bible is a symbol of
warfare
so this is the gospel going into the
world and it is a form of war
it is a form of war against the forces
of evil
[Music]
now the riders that are sitting on these
horses
symbolize the message
so they're not literal people if they
were
literal people then you'd run into a
problem because
one of them is called death
if you go to verse 7 when he opened the
fourth seal i heard the voice of the
fourth beast say come and see and look
there was a pale horse remember
and his name that sat on him was death
now is death a real person or is it a
consequence it is something that happens
so you cannot say that it is the
antichrist so
the horse is white and the color white
symbolizes
righteousness yes so this is the first
message that goes out it's the message
of the unadulterated pure gospel
as christ delivered it to his disciples
and they have a bow also a symbol of war
and it's interesting that god in the old
testament is often depicted with a with
a bow in his hand
and arrows in his quiver so
the white horse symbolizes the
unadulterated gospel
going into the world like
a weapon of war to destroy
evil or to conquer evil and
the messenger that sits on it is
the message that brings the message of
jesus christ
referring to the one with the bow
so it's salvation in christ and it's a
pure
unadulterated gospel if you go to the
second seal
then there was another horse and that
was red
and power was giving given him that sat
there on to take peace from the earth
and that they should kill one another
and there was given him a great sword
so what happened immediately after the
gospel went out in its
purity as soon as you start preaching
the gospel there's something called
enmity and
anger because that is the way of cain
if abel does something that is righteous
cain will kill him so this is exactly
what happened
you had the time of persecution red is
the color of blood
red is the color of sacrifice
self-sacrificing heralding of the gospel
so it was a red horse the gospel said
still went forth but it was based in
blood
but the blood was a seed for
more people to accept the truth
and then eventually comes the black
horse
well black is pretty dark isn't it it's
sort of like the dark ages
where uh the balances a judgment
is is in the play so this symbolizes the
dark ages
when the gospel was
virtually destroyed
and then it got worse then there was
death so you had a contrast
from going from a pure white gospel to a
gospel of death
what is the gospel of death one that
doesn't lead to salvation
it leads to permanent death it leads to
the second death that's why it was
called
the rider was called death and hades
which means the grave
was the consequence eternal death
eternal obliteration
they had replaced the gospel
of salvation in christ with the gospel
of
form and tradition and
relics and everything
but the creator so they start worshiping
the created things and things of their
own devising
and they develop entirely new
gospel so that writer represented
purity of the first message that went
out thank you
oh there's still a last portion here the
writer in chapter six only has one crown
and the writer in chapter 19 has many
crowns now who has many crowns
we even have a hymn that goes crown
him with many crowns well i can't sing
with him
so it symbolizes christ christ
yes now the next question that we got is
why is the sabbath from sunset to sunset
and not sunrise
to sunrise you know
this is actually a very interesting
point
when you go back to creation
then you have the creation days
following each other and it always says
from and it was evening and it was
morning
the first day and the second day
starts with evening and morning and so
we go through
so the day in the bible starts
where the sun sets that's when the day
starts
now why is that important if you take
the modern day which of course
was introduced by roman catholicism
again
then it went from midnight to midnight
now sensible people
let's put it that way are they
normally awake at midnight no
no so the day comes when you're asleep
right
it doesn't affect you and
morning when would morning be let's
define at sunrise if you want to is
everybody awake at sunrise
not necessarily no is everybody normally
awake at
sunset yes
so you can actually greet the day
and what a way to start the day by
greeting the day
as it arrives preparing to rest
and then experience a
mini resurrection when you wake up yes
in that day live your day until
the sunset and then say goodbye to that
day and greet the next one
so when is the more logical time to
start the day
at sunset or at midnight sunset
sunset so from sunset
to sunset shall the day be that's how
god defined it
and then in leviticus 23 32 it says
it shall be unto you a sabbath of rest
not talking about ceremonial sabbaths
but it applies to all sabbaths and you
shall
afflict your souls in the ninth day of
the month
at even from even
unto even shall you celebrate your
sabbath
so even the ceremonial sabbaths were
from sunset
the sun said you can greet it coming you
can
greet it going now the other interesting
thing is
if you wanted to really desecrate the
sabbath
now in some places in the world sunset
is early in some places sunset is very
late
if you go into the northern latitudes
and at summer the sun
sets very late and in some areas
it hardly sets at all right the sun
comes down
dips down to the horizon and then goes
back up again
so how would you calculate your sabbath
from the lowest point to the lowest
point
right that would be exactly the same
thing
so if you wanted to desecrate the
sabbath
then how about making it midnight to
midnight
you start your parties when the sun goes
down
and you keep them going until
midnight saturday night
that means you've destroyed the entire
sabbath
and then you have a rest
on the first day of the week which is a
common working day
and you have managed to trample on the
sabbath when is the worst
party time in the world
yeah i wanted to ask hour-wise or
day-wise
today in the world today friday
um friday evening till sunday morning
yeah until at least saturday midnight
right
so then you've really destroyed the
sabbath so that's the most
drinking the most carousing the most
licentious
time of the week in modern
in the modern world is it a
plan to desecrate the sabbath well
if satan is behind it definitely that's
right
so if your sabbath is from sunset to
sunset
the children are involved the whole
family is
involved and it can be
a very special time change that time
and you create chaos absolutely thank
you
how will a universal sunday law death
decree
work over different timelines you know i
thought about that many times
and then the decree
goes out from which country according to
scripture
united states goes out from the united
states
of america now
there was an occasion when there was
a war called desert storm
and it was the war between the united
states and
iraq and the united states set an
ultimatum and there was an interesting
ultimatum to saddam hussein
and it says midnight
standard eastern time your time is up
so when is standard eastern time
standard eastern time is the
time on the east coast in other words
new york time that's where the united
nations are
situated right yes symbolically
so when decrees go out then
especially if they have the sanction of
the united nations
then it is always standard eastern time
so if you're going to have a
universal decree will it be
a standard eastern time will it be a
united nations
in decree involving the united nations
most probably
most probably so standard eastern time
irrespective of what the time is
anywhere else
in the world yes yeah that makes a lot
of sense
what is the difference between
seventh-day adventist
and seventh-day baptist
now the seventh-day baptist they
believe many things that the adventists
also believe
their gospel
is the same salvation by faith
in christ's atonement and
they keep the seventh day in other words
the law
is very prominent in the religious
system
and the seventh day sabbath is honored
as the day of the lord
so those are commonalities between
adventists and baptists
even the temperance movement was very
strong
amongst the baptists and the seventh-day
baptist
as well so there are many many
commonalities
the differences are when you come to
some special features like the sanctuary
message
the state of the dead is another
interesting
one that is different but it is
that when the adventists were formed a
very high percentage
actually came from seventh-day baptists
who
accepted and embraced these
special doctrines so initially
there was very little difference and
then
as as light became more prominent
and light is progressive more and more
light until the full dawning of the day
then there were some distinctive
features
that were added okay thank you
well here's another question that we
received
where it states in the question jesus
quotes scripture in mark 12
24-25 and the same is mentioned in
matthew 22
verse 29 to 30 but that actual scripture
is not found in any of the 66 books so
where's jesus quoting it from
okay let's go there let's go to mark
chapter 12
24 and we don't have to go to
matthew because it's the same
so mark chapter 12 verse 24
reads and jesus answering said unto them
do you not therefore er because you know
not the scriptures
neither the power of god now let's go
back to the context of the story
you'll see in verse 18 it says then came
unto him the sadducees
which say there is no resurrection
and they asked him saying master moses
wrote unto us if a man's brother
die and leave his wife behind him and
have no children
that his brother should take his wife
raise up seed unto his brother
and there were seven brethren and the
first took a wife and dying left no seed
and the second took her and died and
left
any seed and the third likewise and the
seven had her and left no seed
last of all the woman died also in in
the resurrection therefore
when they shall rise whose wife shall
she be of them
for the seven had her to wife
so the sadducees didn't believe
in a physical resurrection they believed
in a spirit world
by the way what does the modern world
believe what happens when you die
in modern thinking you go to heaven or
you go to hell we go
and you're a spirit right so you're a
spirit
floating up there on cloud nine
maybe with the harp and uh
it's not a physical world it's a
spiritual world
and if you take eastern religions then
they also
spiritualize them away and in some
religions you become
part of of god and you just become part
of the
of the essence yeah the energy
yes so the bible teaches
a physical death and a physical
resurrection will these dry bones live
again
we read that in ezekiel right so will
these dry bones
live again will there be a resurrection
now jesus said i am the resurrection and
the life did he
in his ministry prove that he was the
resurrection and the life
yes he raised the widow's son
he was dead he was being carried
by the pallbearers and jesus stopped the
paw bearing train
and went up and said woman
don't cry and he said to the young man
who was lying there dead young man
get up yeah and he arose
he also resurrected other individuals
and children were resurrected
and lazarus was resurrected and lazarus
in his resurrected physical body
was the one who led the cult
on the great day when jesus
entered in the triumphant entrance so
jesus
clearly taught a physical
resurrection the graves would literally
open now the sadducees didn't believe
that
they believed you became part of the
spirit world
so that is the question
now when jesus says when he addresses
them
when he answers them and says
do ye not therefore er because ye
know not the scriptures is he quoting
him
no he's not quoting the scriptures at
all
in fact what he is referring to is all
the scriptures concerning the
resurrection
they greatly er and so the modern world
also greatly earth they do not
know the scriptures that the dead
know nothing in my flesh
shall i see god says job
you will call and i will hear your voice
he said to daniel you daniel go and
rest and you will stand in your lot
in the latter days i will resurrect you
so a death and a resurrection
and then he says further
when he says ye know neither not the
scriptures
neither the power of god they don't
understand the power of
god that god has the power to
resurrect someone back to life in a
physical form
that's why jesus demonstrated it that's
why he called himself the resurrection
and the life i go to prepare a place for
you
and when i come again i will i will take
to where i am also when i come again not
before
yeah so the modern world follows the
teaching
of the sadducees and then he says
for when they shall rise from the dead
they neither marry nor
given into marriage but but are as the
angels
which are in heaven
so in other words whatever happened in
this world
it will be different how it will be
different
the bible doesn't say so
let's leave it at that what he said
there
is how it is take it as it stands
and leave it at that and so sorry and
when
knowing god whenever he says something
will be better because he says heaven
will be better whatever it is and
however it will be it will be better it
will be better maybe the relationship
will even be
deeper on a different level who knows
now i was always
[Music]
pretty disgruntled over these verses
because you kind of get very
used to and fond of your spouse so
you wouldn't want the situation to
change in any
way but then as you said i would
conclude
that whatever will come must be
better than what was and leave it at
that
good so god won't make you
unhappy correct and definitely be happy
with what
so by the way it seems as if the whole
world
is confused as to the scriptures
regarding this issue and they do not
accept
the abundant evidence
of a physical resurrection
when is it science and when is it
playing god
i think this refers to
when we talked about the vaccine
vaccines yes when are you playing god
when are you practicing science when is
when is it good and when is it not good
what now i was a scientist myself
i also was involved in experimentation
i was part of the ethics committees of
the universities where we had to
discuss and evaluate the ethics of
any scientific experiment that is
undertaken
now when is it science and when is it
playing god
is there anything wrong with
investigating
the way things work in the universe
no no that is man's
inquiring mind and god gave us
inquiring minds and we want to know
the bible tells us that solomon the
wisest man that ever lived
was an expert in zoology he was an
expert in botany
he was an expert in many many things
so it is part of human nature
to study nature when you start placing
yourself
above the god of nature then you are
starting to play god
now when it comes to the genetic system
this gets a bit complicated
if you're saying that you can improve
the genetic system then you don't
believe that god made it perfect
and therefore you will be playing god
when you try to do that now let's make
another situation what if
through sin and deterioration
genetic aberrations came into the world
which they did and these genetic
aberrations
cause disease can
you repair that if it is within your
capability
in other words can you intervene in the
genetics
knowing full well that you are
altering the blueprints of cells
in my opinion it's just my opinion
if you can correct a wrong
that has occurred or something that has
become
or that has deteriorated that is science
and you can you can
cure diseases this way if you
have gene sequences missing and you
replace them
with the correct one by placing them
into stem cells
etc etc and and correcting
what went wrong and thereby alleviate
suffering suffering that is not playing
god
that is using what is there
when you start adding genes
in other words to give capabilities that
were originally not planned and
therefore
you are altering the blueprint of god
then you are playing god
so when you want to amalgamate
animal genes with human genes
then you are playing god because god
created them
in kinds with tremendous variability
a kind was not a species a kind was
probably at the level of a family
so you would have a family let's say
the dog family belongs to
the k-nets they're the
candy dye and every
one that fits into that family would be
the jackal the fox the wolf
uh all the dogs varieties that we have
they would all
be of the family gonna die
so they're all canids so that is one
category
and if you took one pair of those then
the
gene variability for everything that
exists in the world today
was present in that
when you start mixing kinds
genetically by force amalgamating them
and you're playing god then you're
messing with the blueprint
so anything that is for
the advancement of health
correcting things that have gone wrong
that would be
making a proper use of science it's a
very fine line
it's a very fine line and where you draw
it depends
on your parameter
your moral parameter like you also said
in the previous one if your
outset point is evolution then
most probably you will be trying to play
god
if it's evolution then you obviously
think you can improve everything
now even if you take the manipulation
of fruits and vegetables and grains etc
and we think that we can improve yield
and all of these things
now if you go back into
uh history when you go back to let's say
egypt
grain that was there how many coins did
it have in it
a hundred now today if you have 50
you are really pushing it you will be
overjoyed if you get
50. so have we
improved or have we gone back gone back
yeah there's been a deterioration
now i have no problem with breeding
programs to get the very best
yield that you can have but once you
start
adding genes then
you are changing the physiology you
don't know what the effect of that added
gene
is for example if you add
the growth gene
to the genetic makeup of something
let's say the growth genes the genes
that code for
growth hormone in pigs and you
translocate that
into another species then you will get
or even to the same species if you
double it up
you will get giant pigs
and some of them are so diseased because
they're not
the rest of the body is not designed for
this doubling up so that you have to
keep them alive with
antibiotics they can't even walk you
have to squirt them down with hoses
and you say that is an improvement
because you're getting a bigger yield
but you're getting a very unhealthy
yield is that something that you would
like to eat
something that is exceedingly unhealthy
and has been kept alive with antibiotics
and all kinds of things
and what what if you start translocating
genes
across species or maybe even from animal
to plant
they've translocated genes from pigs
into
tomatoes is it then still a tomato
no it might look like it
but how is its physiology affected how
is
the combination yeah uh affected
so uh i'm i'm one to
say let's take the very best
genetic systems that we have
and propagate those and if you can get
great yields then
well then fine but you don't have to
genetically manipulate it
in order to get what you have to do so
it's a very fine line
yeah and depending on who you talk to
you'll get a different answer
what do you think about the use of
spices
well you don't want your food to taste
bland right
and what is a spice and what is a
condiment what is something that
enhances flavor there are many things
that are natural that you can enhance
flavors with
herbs salt
and
some proteinaceous products you could
add
to your foods but a spice normally
has a stimulating effect and is an
alkaloid normally so it has a harmful
effect it has a side effect
so food that is simply prepared with
with herbs and with natural
plant-based condiments that are not
alkaloids are the ones that
would be best for your health so
natural flavourants you could you could
use
a natural yeast flavor and food yeast
for example
you could use salts and herbs
those are all things that enhance flavor
but when you get to things like pepper
okay and paper white and black
white and black or any one of those
then you are adding something that also
has
negative effects and should be avoided
do you know of any substitute for
pepper cayenne pepper okay
cayenne pepper is made from a fruit
right
and the capsicum that is in it is the
one that gives the sharp taste and it
has
some health benefits as well it uh
it's very good for circulation etc and
the taste is the burning taste that you
get with this
cayenne pepper is is not really a
burning
so it doesn't have the effects of
black pepper so you could use that okay
here is a statement from
the great controversy that refers to the
albigensis
in a favorable fashion and the question
here is
everything i have been able to research
on the albiganses
qatars suggests that they were
predominantly
gnostic people is that true as ellen
white speaks favorably of them in the
great controversy
now when it comes to the history of
the waldensians when it comes to the
history of the albert genesis
and when it comes to the history of the
nations
that were uprooted uh
the austroguls the vandals etc
then much of the history that we have
is from roman catholic sources
they claimed that these people were
gnostic
when actually they themselves are
because they in their catechism teach
that
you become god right that's gnosticism
so it was the great aryan conspiracy
these people
were against the view of the godhead
that roman catholic catholicism espoused
and therefore they eradicated them off
the face of the earth
the albiganses the valdensians
waldensians for example they say
oh they started with with peter waldo
and this was very late in the history
when the actual history of the albic
of the valdensians goes back all the way
to the apostles or just after the
apostles
so there's lots and lots of evidence of
that so when you read these negative
things about these people
it's because the enemy of all
righteousness
doesn't want the truth to be told these
people believed in the scriptures
the scriptures unadulterated scriptures
as they stand
they kept portions of scripture in their
sleeves
and they were missionaries to the gospel
they separated themselves from rome
they were sabbath keepers and
therefore they were the enemies of rome
yeah and you cannot
read what rome says about them and
many of the history books have been
totally destroyed
the libraries have been eradicated
so you can only read it through the eyes
of roman catholicism there's pretty good
evidence
that the nations that were eradicated by
rome
were actually sabbath-keeping nations
bible-believing people
and so you can take with a pinch of salt
or what the history books tell you even
when it comes to the history of the
reformation
many many things have been changed in
the encyclopedias
and the jesuits have their finger in all
of those
pies that is why
i love very old bongs
and if you look behind us here you will
see
horrible looking books this is an
encyclopedia
yeah that hasn't yet been tampered with
so if you want to read about some of the
history of
the reformation you get an old mouldy
book that looks like that totally moth
eaten
and you start reading it in this then
the probability
that a jesuit has had his fingers in
that pie
are somewhat lower yes yes and that will
also be the reason because of all that
wonderful knowledge
that the rack might be slagging a bit
that's fine yes rather that knowledge is
heavy
yes so everything that you research on
these people
is not necessarily the truth
thank you here's an interesting question
that we received
is it too late for people like me
guys like you have been preparing
mentally and spiritually for decades
while i've been cruising through life
as if i had the rest of eternity to
spare
is it too late for people like me
the answer is an unequivocal no
it's definitely not too late
now
i think i can say this because my dear
mother-in-law who i
i loved very much no longer is with us
and she was very atheistic
and she was not very fond of the idea
that we had embraced
biblical truth and so she would
always find something to be at odds with
when it comes to the scriptures
and at one stage i had a conversation
with her and she said you know
this bible it's very unfair
and the parable that jesus tells is also
incredibly unfair because there's this
parable
where workers are hired for a day's
wages
and some start early and then later in
the day he finds more
workers and he says come and work in my
vineyard
and then later somebody else comes and
it's
11th hour there's someone that
also is found and he says come and work
in the vineyard
and then when the day is over he pays
them their wages
and they all get exactly the same wage
she says that's ridiculous
that is so unfair and that is why i
don't
like this bible because it has these
ridiculous stories in them
so i said yes but why did you misread it
what if the wage is not money
but the the reward is eternal life
would you like half eternal life a
quarter eternal life
a fraction of eternal life what is
eternal life
it's either all or nothing right yeah so
did those that worked longer in the
vineyard complain
yes they complained and said yeah
we've been sweating ourselves into a
coma here
and these guys come and breeze in in the
last minute and here they are
and he said what didn't i negotiate
with you for a day's wages and you said
that's fine
now you're getting a day's wages why are
you complaining what's wrong with you
they sound like a trade union right
they always want to slice up the cake
i once drew a cake on the board
because i refused to join trade unions
and i was pressurized at my work to be
part of the trade unions
i'm getting off topic but that's what
what's up's all about that's right
and they were nagging me and said how
can you be the head of the
zoology department and not be part of
the trade union you must be part of the
trade union
so i went to the blackboard and i drew a
circle
and i said that's the cake that's the
entire economy of the country
and i drew the slices of cake and then i
wrote the names of the trade unions
into the various slices
and i said okay so here's the teachers
union
and it feels it's slices too small
so it has a big lobby and it starts
climbing on the barricades and
eventually its slices
increased what does that mean to
some of the the lesser slices what
happens to them then become smaller they
have to become smaller because there's
only one total economy
and my question is is that love your
neighbor as yourself
yeah and if your answer is no
well then that's so so the slice is what
it is right
so what happens to people like me
the lord tells you come work in my
vineyard go and work in his vineyard
because salvation is by faith through
grace
and it's not earned yeah so if it's not
earned it's a gift to gift
and the gift is determined by the giver
not by the receiver
if i want to give you a gift you don't
come to me and say hey
this is more for me i want something
bigger i say well then
get yourself into a knot because you're
not getting anything then right
so the gift is determined by the giver
so my dear friends
it's never too late it wasn't too late
for the
thief on the cross right i mean
so we've been preparing mentally and
spiritually for decades
yes and some people who've been
preparing mentally
for decades could be on the garden path
right yeah
so let's always remember that salvation
is by faith through grace
thank you amen what is the biblical view
on security and defending yourselves or
your loved ones
please
okay is the christian necessarily
a wimp no
no he's not a woman but his weapons
are not carnal yes is that right right
okay so peter had a sword
and he tore it out and he went heck
and he cut an ear off
and the lord picked up the ear and put
it back
that should have told that person
something right
and he said put back your sword
and he said there are two swords and
then he said
it's enough enough all right now roman
catholicism
likes to interpret this in their way
they like to interpret it that the two
swords are
the sword of the of the civil power
and then the sword of the religious
power and that the sword of the
religious power
is above the sword of the secular power
the one is subject to the other
just as the spiritual is higher than
the secular so that's how they interpret
it
so they believe they have both swords
but that's not what the lord said he
said put it back yeah
and then peter started using a roman
catholic argument
and said i've got two and
jesus knowing how long it would take to
explain that one says
it's enough put it away
our weapons says the bible are not
carnal
so we trust
in god now when i became a christian
i also had guns
i don't have them anymore i got rid of
them
and i like to trust that god
will take care of this of all things now
do bad things happen to obedient people
as well
yes yes definitely does god know about
it yes
has he got things under control yes
are there thousands and thousands of
stories out there
of god intervening
absolutely all right let's take a few
stories in the bible
when they wanted to uh throw jesus off
the edge of the cliff
he just walked through them right yeah
now apparently
the spirit of prophecy tells us that
angels
were all around him and they basically
blinded the people
not that they were physically blind but
that they couldn't see what was
happening
and then he was gone right
yeah and i've heard of stories like that
i once had to go into a very
dangerous area where just
prior to the time when i was invited to
go and speak in that area
there were a number of
incidences where people had been killed
and and the way in which they were
killing them was very brutal
it was called necklacing oh yes that's
where you put
a tire around someone's neck filled it
with gasoline
and set the person the light i mean it's
a
pretty horrendous death right
and i was arming and eyeing and humming
and eyeing whether
one should enter under these
circumstances
but i felt it was a call and
my wife felt that if i'm going to go
she's going to go along
and if she's going to go along the kids
are going to go along
okay so the whole family got into the
car
and just the day before people had been
killed there
and when we entered that area there were
people standing there
with rifles with ak-47s
and they were looking for anyone that
was coming in there
into that area and we turned in and we
said a prayer
and they looked right through us they
didn't react
nothing we drove right past them
and we were stunned we went in
we spent the day with brothers and
sisters living in that community
marvelous time preaching and
giving lectures having a meal together
no social distancing at that time
no mosques to hide our identity
and then it was time to go back home it
was like
running the gauntlet right and we said a
prayer
and everybody was of one accord got into
our cars
same thing they were still standing
there they were looking in one direction
when we came from the other
nobody batted an eyelid so my my
question is
did they just ignore us or did they not
see us
they probably didn't see you they
probably didn't see
me right eyes were they were closed
not not physically closed but they just
didn't register
yeah so who can do things like that god
god can do that he's many points in the
bible like that
so what happens if
if you find that someone
is beating up let's say your wife or
your children
would you stand idly by and do nothing
if it is within your capability
would you do something no i certainly
would i would do what i can
yes
i wouldn't have a weapon so even if i
did something
i would have to do it together with god
and there are many cases where there are
reports
of people that were seriously in trouble
and prayed
and then someone would appear and
either a high-ranking official
or a very large person and these people
would scatter
and then when you turn around to thank
the person that person is gone i know of
many experiences like that
so trust in the lord with all thine
heart
and lean not on thine own understanding
in all thy ways acknowledge him and he
shall direct thy path that's proverbs 3
verse 5 and 6 i think it's one of my
favorite verses
so yes it's something that one has to
experience
it's something that one has to learn as
far
as is possible
be of a gentle spirit
i had an interesting case
some time ago i was in
south america and i was doing a campaign
in south america
and a young lady came up to me
and she said that she had been through
many of my series
and that she and her husband and her
children
were sitting and they were going through
the series
when there was an attack on their home
and
three robbers came in with guns
and they held the husband and the
children at gunpoint
while one of them grabbed her
and dragged her to her bedroom
and what was she going to do
and they were studying the bible and
they were making decisions to follow god
and so she prayed
and said lord what must i do i mean this
was a very serious situation for her
and probably they were going to kill her
husband and her children
and then she
went to the attacker and gave him a hug
and told him that god loves him
and he got very furious and then
eventually he screamed at her and says
he's a criminal god doesn't love him and
she said yes he does
and so he didn't do what he was going to
do
but dragged her violently back to
her husband and her children and
threw her basically down and there she
was
and they were all held at gunpoint and
she
kept saying to them to all three of them
now
that god loved them and two of them
threw their weapons down and ran out
they left their weapons behind they ran
out
and then the third one if i remember the
story correctly
was the one that had dragged her to the
room he
lingered and said but god can't love him
and she says yes he does she must he
must read the bible he says it doesn't
have a bible
they were busy with the bible so that
she took her bible and gave it to him
[Music]
and then he threw his weapon down and
ran out
with the bible so he exchanged his
weapon for a better weapon for a better
weapon
so there's my philosophy this is my
not this thing but
this this is a tool yeah this
is the weapon yes yes thank you
my job is to care for handicapped people
that means
also on the sabbath and then the person
says that it's very hard
for them to keep the sabbath and that
their pastor
has all kinds of controversial ideas
regarding all of this so
how should he keep the sabbath
well is the sabbath for doing good
or for doing nothing for doing good
the sabbath is for doing good so if
part of your work is to take care of
sick people then that is not violating
the sabbath
if it is your job and you can
exchange a day so that you
work on a sunday for example and
somebody takes the saturday
that is not convicted on the sabbath
issue
then that is a way to get around it
so yes try and keep the sabbath
in terms of worshiping god
but if it entails taking care of those
that are in need then that is part
of the sabbath it's interesting there
was a
medical institution that was
financially in trouble
and they made a decision to
offer their services on the sabbath for
free
and of course they got a lot of
discussion regarding this because this
would make matters even worse
but eventually they actually did that
and they got such a good reputation
that so many referrals came their way
because of what they did
that they actually managed to get out of
financial difficulties
because they decided to do what is right
on the lord's day wow
yeah so the motto simply is do what is
right do what is possible and leave the
consequences
to god amen can you please
expand on this verse it seems so
applicable to our time during
my study of daniel this verse was
referenced
isaiah chapter 30 verse 28
and his breath is like an overflowing
stream and reaches even to the neck
to sift the nations with the sieve of
destruction and a bridle that causes
them to err
will be in the jaws of the people
let's read that in context from verse 27
which is the beginning of a new
paragraph by the way in the original
behold the name of the lord cometh from
afar
burning with his anger and the burden
thereof
is heavy his lips are full of
indignation
and his tongue as a devouring fire
and his breath as an overflowing stream
shall reach to the midst of the neck to
sift the nations with the sieve of
vanity
and there shall be a bridle in the jaws
of the people
causing them to earth
now this is a reference to the day of
judgment
when god will come to judge the world
and he will trample the nations the
bible says
the image in daniel is destroyed when
that stone that rock jesus christ
strikes the political systems of the
world
and destroys them now there is something
in
in scripture which is called
god's permissive will
god's ultimate will
and god's will now god's
will is always in harmony
with his ultimate will
so what was god's original will
god's original will was
peace and love
and gentleness and kindness
and obedience to god's precepts right
yes and that is how the world started
then god's ultimate will
is exactly the same as the original will
that's god's will yes in between we have
a slice
which is called god's permissive will
now in hebrew thinking
god's permissive will is still god's
will
but it's not his original world and it's
not his
ultimate will it's a slice an
interposition
into eternal peace
that has been sliced in
and that is why you have the strange
language
where it says there for example
uh there shall be a bridle in the jaws
of the people causing them to earth
and you find a similar thing in the new
testament therefore god
will send them a powerful delusion that
they may believe the lie
now does god send the powerful delusion
no he permits it he permits it it's part
of his permissive will
when he says send a lying spirit into
that man
is god a liar bible says god cannot lie
then obviously it's god's permissive
will god permits that a lying spirit
take over that person because the person
refuses to accept the truth correct
there's one instance also where god
asked
who will go yes then satan stood up and
satan said i will go yes you go and you
go and do that
in other words that's god's permissible
now why does god have this permissive
will
well if he didn't have you and i
wouldn't be here
simple as that we would have been
destroyed because god's will is the
wages
of sin is death that's it we would have
been gone
it is god's grace that there is god's
permissive will
and god's permissive will will
ultimately lead to the inoculation of
humanity
against this thing called sin and
therefore make it possible for god's
ultimate world to be in harmony with his
original will
wow that's how it works so when you read
these things and you think wow
god is the one who is being the one who
is mean here
no god has
through his permissive will allowed
all of these things and then
comes the retributive action once
that time period that has been allowed
that has been sliced in is
over then let them that are righteous be
righteous though
let them which are wicked be wicked
still
and it comes to an end and god will do
what the bible calls
his strange work
work that is not in harmony with his
character
he's not the god of death he's the god
of life
but he will obliterate evil
to get back to his origin to get back to
the original world so that the ultimate
will
will be back in harmony with the
original woman
so that's how you must understand these
verses thank you
could you please comment on the
following verses mark 16 verse 18
and psalms 91 it says that if they
drink any deadly thing it will not hurt
them
no evil shall befall you if there are
deadly ingredients in the vaccine then
it won't hurt us if we believe that god
will protect us
then no harm will come near us
now this the sin
of presumption
lies very close to the track of
faith in fact presumption
is satan's counterfeit for faith
so when does something become
presumption
and when does something become faith
if i say using this example
oh well god will protect me against
anything evil therefore i'll take the
vaccine
that is presumption
if they grab you and say we're going to
force you to take this vaccine and they
hold you down and
inject you with the vaccine can you
claim that promise yes
yes then it's not presumption
and then it's faith can god protect you
against the consequences
yes absolutely what if it doesn't
did god then fail no no he answered your
prayer
with uh no i'll permit this permissive
world right
so when we get to the time
of the latter rain when
when paul was on that island of melitta
and the serpent attached to his hand
that was a symbol of the latter rain
and that certain didn't harm him now in
the period of the latter
reign when god's people are bringing the
loud cry
will they be able to be
killed maybe still because probation
hasn't closed yet
but could this also apply yes absolutely
it's the same with
um all the martyrs or even paul like you
just mentioned the snake but there was
many
other instances there where he was
stoned and left for dead
yes and then but eventually he did die
yeah
i mean there are such amazing stories
in history there's a poem
in german it's a story poem
and it's a true story it's called
fuse empire feet in the fire
and it was about the inquisition
and this protestant was
[Music]
captured by the inquisitors
and they tortured him terribly
and one of the means of torture that the
inquisitor used
was shoving his feet in the fire and
burning him
in order to make him recant his faith
well whatever the circumstances somehow
this man
survived and escaped
and lived somewhere in the country or
wherever he lived
and then there was a big turmoil
and it was probably in the war
the 30-year war between protestants and
catholics
and one night there was a knock on his
door
and the man who was standing at the door
running for his life was the inquisitor
yeah and so
he recognized him but the inquisitor did
not recognize
the man that was to rescue him
so he took him into his house
and that night he struggled with himself
and the struggle was so great that he
turned gray
overnight so he had
gray hair the next morning
and he came to the conclusion
that he should forgive this man
because that is the christian way
and eventually the next morning came
and when he confronted his inquisitor
he forgave him
and that man became a protestant
so these are some things that god
permits terrible things
but eventually something good came out
of it
and you know it's the same with all of
these amazing
conversions how many people did paul
deliver up to be
killed yes many right
many and those that feared him the most
became some of his best friends that's
how it works that's how the gospel of
reconciliation works so
yes god can protect you it doesn't mean
he will but if he doesn't something good
will come out of it
some greater good like fusion fire feet
in the fire yeah
and then also it comes back to yourself
and your decision that not to be
presumptuous exactly
don't be presumptuous but have faith
i always use a simple example
as to what the difference between faith
and presumption is
let's say somebody collapses on the
other side of the street
and two people run across the street
wanting to help that person the one
says it's a very busy street
one says lord let me get to that person
quickly help me across
the street the other one says
i'm on a good mission god will take care
of this and runs across it
or you know i'm invincible now because
i'm doing something good
even if you're in eight years the one is
faith the other one is perception
correct but to the eye of the observer
it looks exactly the same you cannot
tell the difference
that's why presumption is the
counterfeit
of faith wow
and then we have a question
that's a very common question yes
is who are the 144 000
is it a literal or is it a prophetic
number
now this question
comes over and over and over again
and if you look at the composition of
the 144
000 it mentions the tribes right and it
says 12 000 from each tribe
so the question is is this a literal
number do the tribes still
exist no the tribes don't exist anymore
some people think that they do
exist yes and that they migrated
westward and that they constitute some
of the western nations right
but the bible clearly tells us that they
were scattered to the east
and the syrians made sure
that those nations ceased to exist as
nations
and they were pretty brutal about it i
think we've discussed it in
one of the previous ones already yes
there's also a lecture on it i think
yeah so
let's not go there we're not talking
about literal tribes and then also the
composition of the tribes
in the book of revelation is different
to the composition in the old testament
for example the tribe of dan
isn't mentioned in the book of
revelation although
david had mighty men from the tribe of
dan
that are listed as the heroes of dan
so that would seem to make it
a prophetic number rather than
a literal number and there are also
people that will stand with the hundred
and forty
four thousand so
these will be the people that will be
alive
when christ returns that's the 144
thousand
those that stand with them will be
the redeemed right now
he also saw a great multitude standing
with the hundred and forty-four thousand
so exactly who the hundred and
forty-four thousand
are what are they comprised of the bible
doesn't say
and there's a rule of thumb which says
when the bible doesn't say something
then do not speculate beyond what is
written
like we mentioned earlier the question
that the
sadducees at yes on the
wives so may i be tongue-in-cheek
might be naughty because that's part of
our trademark right
i would i would say it's a prophetic
number
but if things continue as they are in
terms of
the apostasy that is happening within
and without
then i'm getting pretty scared that it
could be a literal number
but let's not go there that's just
tongue-in-cheek
here are a few statements which we might
be able to
glean something from this one comes from
the review and herald
march 9 1905 we are to copy
no human being there is no human being
wise enough to be our criterion
not even an organization of a few people
can be set up as a standard for what you
should believe
we have no creed the bible and the
spirit of prophecy
that's what the lord gave us yes the
greater light and the lesser light
we are to look to the man christ jesus
who is complete in perfection of
righteousness and holiness he is the
author and finisher of our faith he is
the pattern man
his experience is the measure of the
experience that we are to gain
his character is our model let us then
take our minds off the perplexities
and difficulties of this life and fix
them on him
that by beholding we may be changed into
his likeness
we may behold christ to good purpose we
may
safely look to him for he is all wise
as we look to him and think of him he
will be formed within
the hope of glory i mean these are
absolutely inspired words yes
let us strive with all the power that
god has given
us to be among the 144
000 it doesn't mean that you will be
part of 140 but be among them yes
and let us do all that we can to help
others
to gain heaven we are to have an intense
interest in christ jesus for he is our
savior
he came to this world to be tempted in
all points as we are to prove to the
universe that in this world of sin
human beings can live lives that god
will
approve now we've dealt with that on
many
levels we must do in our sphere
what we can what we can and god will add
in his sphere what he can
john saw a lamb on mount zion with him
000 having his father's name written in
their foreheads in other words they have
the character
of god impressed upon their nature
on their cognitive thinking
in other words they are sealed they are
so settled in the truth that they cannot
be moved yes they bore the segment of
heaven they reflect the image of god
they were full of the light and the
glory of the holy one
if we would have the image and
superscription of god upon us we must
separate ourselves from
all iniquity we must forsake
every evil way and then we must trust
our cases
in the hands of christ in other words
you must do what you
can what is in your sphere
what is possible for you concerning
or considering your fallen nature yes
while we are working out our own
salvation with fear and trembling god
will work in us
to will and to do his own good
pleasure that is important righteousness
while you must do your part yet it is
god that must
give you aid and sanctify you so you do
what is in your sphere
god does what is in his sphere
well you must do your part christ
makes us penitent that he may forgive us
so even my repentance is not mine
comes from him and that we must
understand so
if you have that then you will
be with a hundred and forty four 000 and
maybe
part of 144 000 should you be
in that generation here's another
statement from manuscript
26 1901 christ
said that there will be those in the
church who will
present fables and suppositions when god
has given grand elevating and noble
truths
which should be ever kept in treasure
house of the mind
when men pick up this theory and that
theory when they are curious to know
something
it is not necessary for them to know god
is not leading them
it is not his plan that his people shall
present
something which they have to suppose
which is not taught in the word it is
not his world that they shall get into
controversy over questions which will
not help them
spiritually such as who is to compose
the 144 000 that's pretty clear
we don't know bible doesn't say
so what's the point of speculating so
what is our part
rather get yourself ready to be part of
the 144
000 right so strive in your sphere
to do what you can
and pray to god for
his sphere to be added
this those who are the elect of god will
a short time
know without question my brother
brethren and sisters
appreciate and study the truths god has
given for you and your children
spend not your time in seeking to know
that which
will be no spiritual help what shall i
do to inherit eternal life
this is the all-important question and
it has been clearly written
what is written in the law how readers
thou
that's a very nice answer to this
question
here's another statement from last day
events page 222 she's
talking here about the mrs hastings who
she claimed was sealed
and would come up at the voice of god
and stand upon the earth and would be
with the 144 thousand
i saw we need not mourn for her she
would rest
in the time of trouble so she's not part
of them she's
with them this gives us another clue
and this one is very interesting from
christian experience
and teachings page 59 then jesus's
silver trumpet
sounded as he descended on the cloud
wrapped in flames of fire he gazed on
the graves of the sleeping saints
then raised his eyes and hands to heaven
and cried awake
awake awake three times three times
that's very uh important that it is
three times
it's very seldom that the bible repeats
something
three times very often twice
verily verily i say unto you all right
that is twice or when he addresses
people
moses moses yeah or
samuel samuel that is true
now here is one of the occasions when he
says it three times so that is
special emphasis the other one that's
very important where he mentions
something
three times is holy yeah holy holy holy
and you find it in the old testament and
you find it in the new testament
so very very prominent so this
is the great culmination of all things
when he calls the sleeping saints
and he says it three times awake awake
awake ye that sleep in the dust and
arise
then there was a mighty earthquake the
graves opened and the dead came up
clothed with immortality
and the 144th shouted hallelujah
as they recognized their friends who had
been torn from them
by death and in the some same moment
where we changed and caught up together
with them to meet the lord
in the air so from this one can elude
that 144 000 are alive yes
at the coming of christ who they are
we don't know so strive to be among the
000 i think with that we can
conclude this episode of questions and
then we can get back to
our study material thank you very much
shall we close in prayer thank you
heavenly father there are so many
questions
and your wonderful book has the answers
help us to be students of scripture
help us to rely on a thus
says the word and not upon human
speculation bless your people as we
prepare for this great event
and even if we are called in that
eleventh hour to work in your vineyard
then may we work with the full strength
and power that you
make available to us and then
hear those beautiful words
where you call us to enter into your
rest
bless us as we continue with our
activities and prepare us
for what is to come in jesus name amen
amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe
click here when the bell appears
click again to get notifications to
watch the next video
click here thank you